it's a Christmas movie it's an action
movie and it's a silent movie well sort
of the upcoming release Silent Night is
a wall to wall action Bonanza that has
sound effects music and general Mayhem
but it has zero dialogue intrigued I
know I am let's take a look at this
upcoming flick to see what we know about
it so far okay so obviously the first
thing to talk about is that the
characters in Silent Night have nothing
to well talk about that's because the
screenplay consisted of stage directions
scene descriptions and I don't know
maybe an emoji here and there but the
one thing it didn't have was any
dialogue for the characters in the
trailer you can see that the main
character godlock is ambushed by a drive
by shooting while he's outside with his
family then you see him in and then out
of the hospital and at one point he
tries to make a sound but nothing comes
out the bullets he took ended up messing
up his vocal cords and he can't talk
anymore now it seems like he's the only
character with that affliction and yet
the screenwriter Robert Archer Lynn
decided to use that as a springboard for
the rest of the movie in other words no
one has any uh other words it's a pretty
cool gimmick if you ask me and while
we've definitely seen some nearly silent
movies lately like a quiet place there
hasn't been one quite like silent night
especially because it's a shoot them up
action-packed Banger it also means it's
probably the only action movie ever
without a character kicking butt and
following it up with a clippy oneliner I
is the baby but hey that's a small price
to pay right godlock is played by the
intensely watchable Joel kinaman who's
been killing it lately in shows like For
All Mankind Hana and House of Cards and
now he's killing it and a bunch of bad
guys in this Revenge fantasy of a movie
in the trailer it's revealed that the
drive by shooting killed godlock son so
he sets out for payback Joel was aware
of what a bold cinematic move it was to
do a movie with no dialogue but he feels
confident that the action nature of the
plot really lends itself to a big leap
like this in an interview with collider
he said quote it was the perfect kind of
script to try this sort of cinematic
experiment it's a very Dynamic action
movie with a lot of heavy drama but the
actual plot is pretty simple and he has
a point any movie where the plot is
super intricate and needing constant
explanation is probably going to be a
big fail without any dialogue I'm trying
to imagine like a Quenton Tarantino
movie with no words and frankly it's
making me giggle but according to Joel
Silent Night is a perfect fit in that
same interview he added quote I think
you really want that in a film where you
don't have any dialogue to explain to
the viewers what's happening so I think
it's going to be pretty easy to follow
and hopefully you'll get all the emotion
just through the eyes and through the
action kenman says if the experience of
watching the movie is anything like the
process of making it then people are in
for an intense good time he said quote I
hope it's going to be pretty damn epic
that's what it felt like when we shot it
of course just because the movie lends
itself to having no dialogue doesn't
mean that it was a breeze to shoot
kinaman talked about how you might
assume it was the easiest gig of his
life especially cuz he had zero lines to
memorize it almost seems like he and the
other actors could have shown up on the
first day and just started punching each
other as the cameras rolled but it was
actually a lot more involved than that
said Joel quote some people thought like
oh that's easy you don't have to learn
any lines but it's not because the eyes
don't lie and in the dialogue it would
help you get emotionally there but
because he didn't have the help that
dialogue would usually give a
performance he had to lean heavily on
his thoughts emotions and subtle
physical movements kenman said quote so
it's actually a lot harder to portray
everything that you just have to have
that kind of inner life and that inner
motor and those thought processes going
for real Joel added that the lack of
dialogue and the intense focus on his
face and actions meant he had to immerse
himself fully into the role he added
quote you you just can't hide so I think
it's very revealing when there's no
dialogue and so it was a great Challenge
and I was very excited that he wanted to
do it with me and who is the he in that
last quote none other than legendary
action director John Woo Woo is an icon
of Cinema especially for action movies
like face off and Mission Impossible 2
and he's been directing over the past
two decades putting out a film every
couple of years but you might not
realize that none of them have been
American Studio films this is actually
Woo's first American film in 20 years
which says a lot about what woo thinks
of the script the actors and the final
product and for Action fans it's a long
awaited return to the American Cinema
Scene woo was pretty effusive about it
calling it a very interesting movie in
an interview he talked about how the
lack of dialogue allowed him to use all
the other elements to tell the story
said Woo quote we are using music
instead of language and the movie is all
about Sight and Sound and this is no
easy feat even with all the time and
money in the world of course woo didn't
have either of those so he had to really
find creative ways to bring out the
movie's potential he said quote the
budget was a little tight and the
schedule was tight but it made me change
my working style but in this movie I had
to force myself to use a new kind of
technique some scenes were about two or
three pages but I did it all in one shot
which also goes to show you the level of
director John is kinaman certainly
appreciated Woo's talent and raved about
how cool it was was working with woo he
also said he was amazed at what woo was
able to accomplish in terms of
Storytelling without having any dialogue
to work with said Joel quote I've never
worked with anyone that tells so much
story just by how he moves the camera if
you're anything like me you've already
watched the trailer like five times I
mean the way they sink up Joel kinman
rapidly emptying out shotgun cartridges
with the trailer music Alone got me
pretty hyped add in the highflying
action the car crashes the explosions it
definitely makes me want to hit up the
theaters when it comes out plus John Woo
you got to love his return to American
film making so are you in have any
thoughts about Silent Night and watching
a movie with no dialogue pop them in the
comment
section